okay today I'm going to talk to you
about distillation we're going to look
at simple distillation we're going to
see a fractional distillation we're
going to see the equipment required and
how it works and the difference between
simple distillation or fractional
distillation okay so let's get started
now this here that we're looking at is
an example of simple distillation you
can use simple distillation when you've
got a mixture of two substances that
have very different boiling points so
let's just imagine here we have a salty
water so the reason why we use new
simple distillation is because the
difference in boiling point between
water and salt sodium chloride is
massive water has a boiling point of 100
degrees C whereas sodium chloride has a
boiling point of 1413 degree C so
because there's a huge difference in
boiling point we can use simple
distillation so what we have here at the
bottom is a Bunsen burner now this could
also be a heating mantle we just need to
heat up this salty water until we get to
the boiling point of water so when this
reaches a hundred degree C we will have
evaporation taking place
so remember evaporation means turning
from a liquid to a gas only the water
evaporates at this stage the salt does
not evaporate because we need a huge
huge amount of heat in order to
evaporate the sodium chloride so it's
only the water that evaporates here we
can see we have steam that starts to
travel down this part here now obviously
the whole point is we want to be able to
collect our liquid water at the end we
don't want steam so we need to turn the
steam back into liquid water and to do
that we use this bit of equipment here
which is called a condenser this thing
here now the condenser needs to cool
down the steam to turn it back from a
gas into a liquid now the way that that
works is we have cold water which flows
in this part here called the condenser
now if you look really really carefully
you'll see that there are kind of two
tubes here the water the cold water
which flows in there flows around that
inner tube it flows around it cooling
down the steam and as it does we have
condensation that's why it's called a
condenser because the steam as it's
cooled down turns back into liquid water
and there we have it right there so we
have clean water right here the salt
remains here because we do not get to
that temperature but the water is
separated turns to steam then as it goes
into the condenser if I was to touch
that it would be cold we turn it back
into liquid water the reason why we
constantly have the water flow in is to
make sure the water stays cool at all
times if we just had the water sat there
it would get warmed up by the steam and
wouldn't work as well so that's simple
distillation the next thing we're going
to look it up is fractional distillation
now the difference between the two is
fractional distillation is used when we
have a mixture of liquids with similar
boiling points or kind of much closer so
let's just imagine we have liquid a
which has a boiling point of let's say
60 degree C let's imagine we have liquid
well we have liquid B which has a
boiling point of 80 degrees C and we
have liquid see liquid C which has a
boiling point of 100 degree C 100
degrees C cool so at the beginning we've
got them all in here so we've got a
mixture of liquids here now we can't use
simple distillation because these
boiling points are all far too close to
each other they become out at the same
time if we use simple distillation or
rather similar times would be very
difficult so instead we have this
fractional distillation column and
towards the bottom of the column it's
hotter
to the heat and towards the top of the
column it's colder now we could tell the
temperature at the top of the column
because of this thermometer which is in
the top so what will happen is stage by
stage each liquid will come out just the
same as before this is the condenser and
the condenser works in the same way by
condensing the the the gas and turning
it back into a liquid so the first
liquid that's going to evaporate is
going to be liquid a it's going to
travel up the column and travel down
here when it gets the condenser that
will turn it back into liquid water if
let's say liquid B evaporates it might
get up to around here on the column and
then it might just drip back down
because it will condense here instead so
the first liquid you would separate
would be liquid a so you can collect
that whole liquid there first what you
could then do is let's say when this
thermometer then reaches 80 you could
then go get another conical flask and
collect your liquid B so you move that
conical flask out of the way because
hopefully all of your liquid a would
have evaporated and now you could
collect your liquid B and finally once
you've done that when this reaches a
hundred hopefully we should be
evaporating liquid C so you then move
that conical flask out of the way and
you can collect your liquid C so quick
recap fraction distillation is used to
separate when we have liquids with kind
of similar boiling points
unlike in simple distillation which we
use when the two different substances
have very different boiling points thank
you very much